I'm married hey there everybody and
welcome to this week's episode of
multiple players I am obviously Sean
McGinnis not Chris Waters he's out on
vacation enjoying the uh the fine
Upstate New York uh vacation prospects
meanwhile
we've got Tom McShay here
who is uh we're trying to come up with
bro names because we're obviously
playing broforce on this week's episode
of the show Tom McShay Tom mcbrough Tom
broche well I should probably be Mick
brosh I'm still Irish Brown okay bro
Alex Newhouse whose new name is Alex Bro
house that works for me yep Justin
haywald Justin browald Justin broble and
I've got my uh collar popped which is
completely unnecessary you don't even
need to do that but we're gonna let you
get away with it and I'm uh Sean
so the game we're playing today bro
Force it's a side-scrolling shooter not
unlike a metal slug but the difference
here is I say Metal Slug Tom you're
giving away the dirtiest look I'm
curious what are the difference is
because metal select's pretty bro it is
very bro yeah uh so the difference here
is you'll find out in a minute okay
so we're all Gonna Get Ready and then
we're all going to confirm that we're
ready
okay wait someone who's going oh come on
get ready
you guys are just
you guys are going nuts so uh four
player co-op in broforce
um as you can see we need to liberate
the first section of Vietnam which is
southeast Vietnam and I trust that man
implicitly because he has a big mustache
and a cigar and
a giant American flag yes
as you will soon find out
all four characters are influenced by
Action Movie heroes and that's the case
for every character that you unlock in
the game
so uh these American flags are
checkpoints so if any one of us dies we
will be able to respawn back there
man Indiana Jones I just have a whip I
need a gun we all kind of look the same
yeah you know who you are based on your
little uh your little portrait I turned
into a I'm carrying somebody oh no no
I'm bigger
there we go oh yes sorry jerks so you'll
notice that that was absolutely batshit
insane
yeah it's going to continue to be that
way right and probably even worse uh
basically
the very first level in the game is very
brief but they'll get a little bit
longer and checkpoints will become much
more of a deal so we all start with one
life and when we rescue one of those
why am I shooting down somewhere what is
happening Sean
oh yeah so you are the girl from uh
Planet Terror okay and so you have a gun
on your leg and that's why you can only
shoot down I will warn you if you get
all the way to the bottom of the map you
will die
so you're gonna be the guy in are you
first player yeah so you are
I'm not a guess that I was upper left
but I'm here I'm
so fire your gun and you'll see your
face light up Tom
your lower left okay I'm a man in Black
I'm a man in Black from will thank you
are you blade you made a blade me yeah
no you look like Mr T no I'm Mr T yes I
know that I'm the Men in Black guys
interesting
now um
sorry because I have a noisy quick I'm
shooting with a noisy Cricket I'm a big
fan of oh I'm out Men in Black not alive
great what happened to me stuck down
there oh sweet somebody was really
screwing us over with this view
Who's down there all right guys go just
die I'm I'm dead I died or you just keep
going keep all right there we go
all right all right well I just killed
myself that was fun got this you got
this red barrels explode some future
reference that's true so I know that in
when you're doing the single player
every time you rescue one of those
hostages you get an extra life and you
get to play as that bro uh I don't I'm
not sure how it works exactly in Co-op I
guess we'll figure that out shortly I
have a grenade launcher here by the way
go down with you all right here we go
guys we're going down [__] I'm already I
didn't need to go down I'm dead oh
you're dead I guess that was death this
is all right it's up to you snake
playskin
we're doing all right
what was the mission okay I was
wondering different characters now one
of you immediately went and destroyed
the only bridge that we have to get over
there so thanks a lot for that oh you
can latch onto the wall yeah you can
just jump up the wall you actually just
climb up with your knife which is great
yeah
I I turned into somebody else
this is way harder with Co-op isn't it
oh yeah it's much harder I'm Gonna Save
Somebody
I'm robot I'm RoboCop
yeah you are Tommy
he's going straight through the wall
oops there goes Chuck Norris Chuck
Norris is down ladies and gentlemen
Who's Alex with the sword
I'm Rambo now is that blade play foreign
I think it depends on who readied up
first I'm in the bottom right okay I've
got a gallon gun sweets and I apparently
have a whip oh my God it's blowing me
backwards I'm two people
that's a really long whip though who's
who are the two people that I am
oh yeah you're The Boondock Saints guys
I'm a demolition dock Saints and I have
a gun oh and I got killed
this is chaos gentlemen but he just
killed all of us all right it's up to
you how did you kill us all it's up to
you all right so you can say if you save
that person that'll bring one of us back
to life yeah kill those guys first
yeah so just shoot it yeah that's for me
one of us is back in who's on the bottom
left me who is that who's on the top
left that's you Alex what is this oh
that's me all right
all right so once again destructible
environments things will fall in your
head if you're not careful
it's all I ask of you
now comes blade I don't know where I'm
at I'm gonna die
all right I've got a prison
flamethrower is that an A-Team reference
oh my God
you need to just kill race the moment
and not worry about logic so much
I never saw the A-Team I know clever
Lane that's my Mr T movement Dear Mr T
character of choice yeah
he didn't have a flame someone else
let's save us go down go down and save
someone oh this is me
how sweet so these are the hostages that
you rescue and they unlock new Bros for
you well player one oh watch out I wish
I could remember their names because
John I know Rambo's got it
all right
he's back
yeah so we should point out this game is
early access that's not even officially
out yet no it's not but you can buy it
on Steam oh wow you can pay for it you
can pay for it on scene
uh guys it's fun yeah
this is way more chaotic than I was
expecting yeah I know four players might
have been Overkill I think two players
would have probably been a sweet spot oh
yeah I'm RoboCop I have a sports
oh there's two Arnold there's two on
screen
yeah he's got a hole
that's a rear of bro characters big time
I hope you get to play as twins
we're Junior oh no there's a whole bunch
of danger up there somebody rescue the
hostage please
I got it he's back so I am someone else
someone else I'm another Schwarzenegger
I'm gonna try to let's get this flag up
on the left
we got this guy got it all right so this
is kind of like a mini boss guy that
really big bulky dude up there yeah I
recommend uh being extremely careful
this dude so what I like to do hold on
just stay still for a second what I like
to do just shoot the ground out from
under him let him kill himself
it's good life advice yeah oh watch out
okay oh nice work all right and now I'm
gonna get rescued see you later damn it
[__] you guys your lines are represented
by grenades naturally no no no no those
are different grenades those are
grenades grenades what's that how do you
use the b b the B button oh we went over
this Justin I wasn't that paying
attention all right so we completed our
first area with this liberated Vietnam
yes well we we liberated Southeast
Vietnam we still got East Vietnam okay
we still got a whole multitude of
Vietnam locations to liberate Tom they
don't even go for you know a fictional
place like now we're just gonna go
straight for you're liberating in
Vietnam yeah okay why not
interesting choice all right well I'm
throwing something all right so I'm dead
already once again gentlemen uh you
really [__] the bed just immediately
does that mean you died all right so it
looks like we've got Mr T I'm throwing
Dynamite sweet I think you are I want to
say you're MacGyver
because you have like uh handcrafted
explosives so
who's the guy in the who's the bottom
right guy bottom right that was me I was
Chuck Norris momentarily
oh and I'm back
I think I'm snake pliskin
we're gonna basically escape from New
York's snake placement I've never heard
of it I know escape from L.A I know
snake places
insane yeah it's crazy
it's much more manageable in single
player my Dynamite just blew up like
half the screen all right who's still
alive uh I was alive but I was sorry
jerks no yeah I was I was on the line
whoa watch out that thing's gonna come
rocking over this way and now I'm gonna
you should just go through take care of
these roses
when you don't have to worry about I
think other people just setting off huge
experiences yeah you know who is the
person who does that that's you Justin
you're the one setting up here that was
me that was I was gonna go like hey Alex
what are you up to oh you killed
everybody killed everybody
you wanted to stay away from other
people in this game what is that what is
that
oh not killed it's kind of it's kind of
throwing ice noses everywhere like
that's your gun here we go all right
guys good wait so before we go I'm
Charles Norris I'm blade I have no idea
who I am I'm Rubble because this thing
uh the yellow you are you're top left I
am you're judged red okay you're judged
red I'm blade Chuck Norris the RoboCop
here we go let's do this oh what is all
right oh I just switched to so everybody
has their own primary weapon and their
own secondary grenade type weapon
although as as blade I don't actually
have a grenade I have like this quick
quick slash Dash
um which is very handy
yes who became agent Jay
all right so I'm still blade
it's so [__] chaotic and four player
oh my God
this flag gentlemen yeah this one's for
America
so lives
what just happened somebody somebody had
to get a nuclear over there all right so
it's just me and RoboCop left all right
good RoboCop let's be careful about this
oops I died
speaking of careful this is all you
RoboCop how does
how do I fire this what's the what's the
secondary I don't know this is my
secondary is doing yeah he's got
robocops kind of like uh I don't know I
ran out I guess I used to have a
secondary attack though yeah right I was
trying to use my my special taking the
easy way out there you go you got us all
back in it oh you get a checkpoint that
gets everybody
two people
yeah your plane is uh Boondock Saints
right right I'm trying to keep up here
with these references yeah Alex Newhouse
being our intern who's only about eight
years old he doesn't understand a lot of
the references to those classic 80s and
90s action romps probably because oh God
there's a truck on my head oh it didn't
kill you it didn't kill me because I
know I just want to say that so far we
have completely shirked the option of
playing as a team communicating with one
another and moving at a deliberate Pace
that is an option I just want to throw
that out there yes instead what we have
is Tom McShay
um just Buckwild shooting everything in
sight I was shooting the people that
were bad I'm just saying I'm just saying
we could communicate if we wanted to
because somebody else when you fire
there's an explosive at the other end of
your bullet yeah wait wait wait wait
okay wait stop stop stop stop hi Mark
all right okay and somebody died wow
okay so
I am a guy from I think I'm Arnold from
Predator maybe MacGyver I am I'm Mr T
for the flamethrower all right Whoever
has the explosives that's me yeah that I
have explosives no I also have
explosions
oh nice you're just burning men alive
oh watch out those are mines oh yeah so
usually yeah be aware of those are mines
watch out there's an explosive here it's
going to go the opposite direction there
we go there you go yeah teamwork
communication C all right I'm watching
for that truck so kill that truck I'll
do it
just like that all right make sure one
pro tip is there are often Bridges don't
destroy the bridges please yeah ah
what's gonna happen all right checkpoint
we're good
you can you can definitely burn the
bridges
all right somebody dead oh no all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna rescue this yes
yes I'm back all right so all right
sweet get back is uh
awesome
yeah Chuck Norris and I'm David again
yeah because you just are terrible yep
all right so I'm gonna save this guy
this is I don't I'm not sure like how it
determines it's just random yeah it's an
order of death
I'm Neo
I had a pretty city weapon
would it be better do you think if the
whole camera has panned out more to show
more of the stages he spread out or is
it better to stay in place I feel like
it probably would be oh now I became
machete oh I died
that's the thing about like the co-op
character switching is that there's so
many characters on the screen yeah that
you often can't tell when you've taken
on a new persona
I liked when you also said earlier those
are landmines be careful and then you've
walked over you jumped over them and
then went back we're like come on who
shot the ground up from under me that
was great
that was tough yeah what
I'll take care of these landmines
gentlemen
Walker Texas Ranger
cool shouldn't you be then you know
fighting with kicks oh God that one I'm
gonna get across the bridge before you
guys destroy it it might be machete
machete jumps really weird
they're not in a good not a good kind of
weird either
oh craps their bullets are much better
than yours
all right here we go oh you guys are
still alive there's so much more
coordinating than all of us well because
I've done a lot of the the solo campaign
that would probably do it I'm back and
now I just burned a man alive okay so
here's the way it works for anybody
who's wondering
um
if all four of us are alive and we
rescue a hostage then the person who
rescued that hostage becomes that
character however if one of us is dead
and we rescue a hostage
the person who is dead then becomes that
character so
anybody who's curious
so remember there's no timer
you don't have to run through and just
immediately
oh no
okay no
we got this all right yeah we got this
we got this don't set off oh [__]
don't set off the road okay never never
mind
yeah all right well I'm dead again watch
out all right wait that's an explosive
turkey
what does that mean I'm still alive oh
wow summer oh wow you're playing with
fire there
watch out I'm gonna plant a bomb
oh you're doing your your bullet time I
think
your grenade must be bullet time Neo
time
don't push me onto the minds you [__]
can you push people you somebody pushed
me
all right wow
okay who's who's back in it Terminator
okay all right Terminator
that's sweet
look at this WOW
slow and steady you don't have to run
through at top speed just get to the
checkpoints
X yeah
oh
what so is there a versus mood to this
as well there is there is a death match
we didn't try that oh is someone Batman
oh another blade
I killed myself
all right machete
to follow blade never mind here blade is
just going full areas on this
I like his style okay would you be able
to just ride
the uh thing you know except one of
those explosive gas tanks and just ride
that to the end of the stage
oh come on machete cool we're gonna save
you oh you're back in it Sean oh I'm
back in it oh I'm Rambo
wait no I'm all right my skin it's hard
to tell there's so many characters with
the headbands just white dudes with the
headbands oh dang I can't shoot
80s action movies
all right I'm back
all right watch out yeah when you're
indoors you will get crushed by Falling
objects that's just a thing that's gonna
happen all right I'm gonna bring
somebody back to life
there we go you're Neo is that Neo with
the eyebrows
what those are those are sunglasses
they're sunglasses Tom come on man
they're all eyebrows oops I died
somebody rescue that guy somebody rescue
that guy
watch out for the big boss watch out for
the big guy here we go
oh God
oh that was a that was an explosive
Scarlets here here here I try to go
underneath them but then I made uh but
he fell on me by accident
don't need a kill I think the flag is
just up here so sometimes you see if you
go you go right I'll go left okay you
see free to play games like this that
co-opt a lot of characters how are they
getting away with this this one yeah
well this isn't free right this is
parody Paris this has been protected for
millions of years yeah millions millions
of years
am I the girl who shoots down
like there's a lot of different
characters this is like only well
there's a dog that we've seen but uh one
thing I've noticed is that the
characters are not super well balanced
some of them have really useful attacks
and some of them like you're down just
shoot down with their leg gun
which is part of the fun because this
game definitely Embraces like the chaos
and
man who ridiculous damage on stop
shooting you're making it really hard
that's the only way that I can travel
well I guess I can normally travel but
who wants to do that so I'm Gonna Save a
hostage ah I need to get back in here
I'm Boondock Saint no I'm dead I'm
regular Boondock guy yeah
hello
you can jump on people's heads yeah
yeah we can't I don't think they've
killed oh my god I've never been Indiana
Jones oh Indiana Jones is super
underpowered yes he's just got away all
right watch out for the big guy all
right so oh come on get it get the flag
oh kill these guys get the flag yes wow
nice work until I did it at the end
there
uh for anybody wondering about verses
we'll do that uh you want to do that
like after the halfway point maybe yeah
yeah should be good sounds good palette
cleanser yes
I am snake skin
am I John McLean lower left oh yeah
you're John McClain because you have no
shoes on and you have your uh dual wield
whoa I'm a new character what which
character am I the sword guy no I'm this
one you're a Conan Barbarian oh yeah do
you mean blades do you know who blade is
Right Onan it's Conan oh you're the
studio guys guys come on that makes
sense
uh one that's a bunch of explosive
barrels
wow I survived it I didn't make the jump
across
all right go rescue that dude
a great victory
okay now I am the uh sunglasses dude his
name is Neo have you never seen The
Matrix I love The Matrix
first one not so much the other two oh I
know there's only one Matrix whoa what
about the Matrix okay all right this
one's on you neo blade
like you're staring it was like a stare
down all right and then he just shot you
come on you just destroyed just go go
for that go for that that's a checkpoint
hit that all right sweet
now we're all back
I don't know who I am I don't want to
hang out with you guys though
I'm just taking off oh so that's about
it's a cut scene yeah
we got this guys oh America there's no
way this is gonna go poor not America
crazy I just killed myself gotta kill
myself yeah the America crates are ammo
refills somebody got that oh I have full
ammo that's why I'm alive
right please oh no I'm still good
the noisy Cricket really pushes you
backwards and you have to constantly
push yourself forward whoa darn it that
shot the ground up and underneath me
oh no so the helicopter blades are
deadly oh yeah not surprising watch out
for that until you touch them
there's a hostage down below I'm going
for him
what was that that was Sean
now who am I playing at
oh you're fine kill it kill it oh darn
it
use your grenade power
it looks pretty amazing yeah this is
no it's still there oh you kill it you
kill it I'm just gonna stand here
still alive
oh those are a bunch of red barrels do
not be anywhere near them they're gonna
go off
oh [__]
oh my God so your strategy so far of
destroying the environment so you have
no place to stand is working out very
well yeah
that's like a ball for YouTube
helicopter
we're good
yeah area liberated I love liberating
stuff yeah just sell America so it is so
good
I think this developer is actually from
South Africa I want to say really
definitely definitely not American
right level red
so this I think is going to be a tougher
area who wants to one of you guys pick
let's go to the city yeah let's go let's
try some Urban Warfare
godspeed bro for us blow up some
skyscrapers here we go so are there any
vehicles in the game or is it always uh
I haven't encountered any vehicles that
you can operate but you can definitely
shoot the [__] out of some Vehicles oh I
got Indiana robots
I'm the cop who's also a robot
oh no they're mine's everywhere one
thing to point in mind is that if you do
have a melee weapon like blade or
something I'm pretty sure that you can
deflect bullets with it
so FYI this is not good for me
oh no I think you're destroying the
bridge
yes oh God oh my God oh my God why would
you follow the propane tank
hostage hostage downtown
I'm gonna get one keep things
interesting
oh so one of you I think is Ripley from
Alien oh I'm Ripley yeah the Bros are
not all dudes which is which is not
just nice oh I'm all right oh my God I'm
just shooting guys immediately
all right great work
what's your name whoa Ripley no I don't
know I don't know I don't know I never
actually I've never seen a movie yeah
neither am I oh sweet someone's back oh
yeah I'm Conan yeah
hey
why it is not letting me up I don't know
oh [__] you pushed me up through then oh
Tom I'm gonna what did I do
exploded everything you exploded all the
Reds
on you I can only shoot down and I
wasn't above red barrels okay so be
careful oh my gosh whoa all right so
here's what I would recommend doing poke
your head up and just throw your grenade
okay don't let it kill you
I don't even know what your grenade is
do you oh don't get killed a lot of
jumping
oh my God
that worked that works that worked
you're good I had no idea what was
happening but
So for anybody who's just tuning in this
is broforce this is a game that's on
Steam Early Access it's a uh
side-scrolling shooter with a lot of
physics destruction and Co-op is super
fun but just so chaotic
yeah fine it's not a grenade it's your
secondary as mad well it's all the time
oh my God on the screen it's listed as a
grenade but it's actually a grenade for
some people oh they're shooting yeah you
guys up there who are shooting if you
jump into their bullets you die those
bullets blend in with the background too
whoa
launcher yeah that's so dumb not my
favorite weapon don't watch it but you
know very infeasible
and now I'm the dude with the eyebrows
oh I'm John McLean you the way you are
blatantly flaunting Hollywood action
tropes it's just makes me so sad
so if you uh if all four players are
alive and one of you rescues a hostage
you then get a bonus like you change and
you also get a bonus life
the camera is a little louder for me in
this yeah yeah it's the camera is a
little nutty in Co-op it's much better
and it's like yeah yeah okay the single
Screen Co-op is always interesting all
right I'm clearing this right I'm back
oh there's a dude oh God I'm gonna check
her grenade
oh
did you see that that was nice
you should go to the rescue
you like that player one save them today
I'm not I'm not even a planetary girl
that's a good thing
happy all right watch it I'm gonna shoot
this it's gonna whoa whoa whoa that
looks like a missile launcher
that is awesome oh watch out this one's
on you this one's on you pleasekin maybe
just shoot
don't let it fall on you all right yeah
there you go wow all right rescue this
hostage
player three I'm in no that's not yes it
is me yeah watch out for the tank
can't only go underneath yeah
because you'll eventually encounter
these gaps where you need to go up and
press
I can see how it would be fun to watch
the devastation whereas here you get to
be a part of other flyers devastation
oh that's me playing a terror girl
what's your name by the way the chat
room what's the name of the get the
Cherry something get the hostage don't
worry I'll shoot down oh 50 T says
Cherry something cherry
all right oh I'm back
where are you uh oh you're uh your Ash I
think
from Pokemon yeah
definitely not ash
oh yeah
because it's Bruce Campbell ladies
Campbell yeah that's his name right
what is it whoa I don't know what ashes
are
just like McLean Ash McLean no I'm gonna
go with Ash Campbell uh oh that guy
killed himself
all right so with that level completed
we're gonna take a quick ad break and
then we'll be back and we'll try out
some you guys want to do verses sure all
right we'll give it a shot stay tuned
we are back uh instead of instead of
jumping to uh-oh versus we just started
playing the next level as soon as we
complete this or I'll die I'm apparently
I'm on the other side come on the other
side please I'm apparently alive
somewhere so oh what I apologize for
that early access game
so you get you definitely get stuff like
that where the camera just loses itself
is this already the boss of this uh this
section all right let's go for it who am
I I'm John McLean I just rescued RoboCop
all right oh God that was a lot here oh
here we go
where am I at
whoa
something oh so one of those tanks shot
up and then hit something and it fell
down on me like a
oh it's the
it's the dead corpse of that mini boss
is what killed me oh we beat him yeah
that wasn't a full boss that was a mini
boss
and I don't know about this RoboCop
other weapon
what do the checkpoints do because we
don't whenever we die we don't seem to
start from a checkpoint so the
checkpoint is more for like single
player where every time you rescue a bro
you get like you stock up on lives so
anytime you die you go back to the oh my
God points yeah I'm working on it the
checkpoints are less useful in um hey
Tom you're back that's not me
whoa I died
that's his other oh he changed his metal
Terminator like yeah that's the
canonical name metal Terminator way to
go all right so now that we have
displayed our incredible knowledge of
yeah metal Terminator Cannon we're gonna
we're gonna try the uh verses
there's also different types race mode
explosion run ooh explosion run you guys
want to try that or do you want to go
Deathmatch Death Match first then we can
go all right we can try explosion run
stuff press fire to continue in on
player one
boom you should you should remember when
players doing I'm player two
I'm I'm player four
player three ready up
I am ready there you go because I'm
player three yeah yeah player three is
always ready
oh
we can only I'll play around
Ronan the Barbarian Brohard Mr Ander bro
bro dread s
some pick your bro I want to see what
they were called well at least they
don't well I don't know
barbarian was pretty sucky yeah because
he's just got a board
Walker
oh I can only choose from these yeah
dicks sorry sorry bro hard
sorry buddy that's just how life goes
oh great I have a
this dude oh
I'm back in oh you're not
boom
earn it you're dead
oh God this we're gonna destroy this
whole map very soon well I guess there's
more map down below which is good
wow all right well
oh God holding an airstrike you destroy
the helicopter America
oh
what is that what does this special do
I don't know [__] I know oh no [__]
somebody kill John McLean there you go
that's how you do it all right it's down
to these two
sounds terrible
oh I get to go it's a different a
slightly different assortment aside from
Judge rambro
I'll go back real quick
oh they switched shoes oh wait I would
never have over to Universal sold here
yeah one of the great forgotten action
movies in the 90s oh is this me
I would have said one of the Forgotten
action movies of the 90s whoa what do
you have against Dolph Lundgren and
Jean-Claude Van Damme
beginning of this oh no when you're all
in cages well I don't know who I am but
I'm not okay
oh
you killed me but how how cool is that
the way I killed you
shot off the ground from underneath you
it's so chaotic
Jesus Oh man
what if you guys just stop shooting me
oh no I killed myself
wow all right well yeah oh
prestigious that can auto scroll damn
foreign
Indiana Jones I don't know wait did that
say the bride
wow
won the first one yeah that was me and
he's a Melee character
or you can whoa hello
oh my God stop
Justin's got the whole helicopter
camping thing down
yeah Jones does have a pistol oh well
that was a good power but he only uses
it on that one guy
no I'm talking about in the game oh
oh no don't jump on the helicopter
blades note to self
we already establish that well that well
that was during the boss
fight really bad
that sword isn't that bad ah it's pretty
good
[__] that sword
that's what I have to say about that
sword
oh my God it felt awesome that was such
a bro death
you got this whoever you are not have
for machete isn't it
bro dick
well it's got lots of proteins there's
so much this whole game is bro dick
Riddick
yes no that was uh that was a
questionable assignment of wrong way to
that name you don't like it what would
you call Riddick not bro dick no Rick
it's definitely gonna be brodix
I don't think how is it not gonna be
brodick
brodick give me one good reason it would
be British not brodick
way funnier all right let's try uh let's
try a different mode Let's try I'm gonna
kind of tweet the developers after this
game and ask them everybody hit B hit B
back out so your player four has to do
it I can't everybody smash the a buttons
no it's one-on-one all right we're gonna
try uh explosion mode explosion run
explode I don't know what explosion run
is sounds good
this is not explaining it
one player three I think I'm playing
player two wait I think I'm player two
what are we doing here this is called
explosion run okay the rules no I got it
what is happening I can't get out of my
cage because I'm Indiana Jones I know
I'm the same thing you should hit B I
think that would open it up oh okay but
I had this wow
all right guys
[__] it's getting exploded
everything is explodable
thanks oh yeah basic remote
oh no this one's on you oh
oh
my God
helicopter but you [__] it up
got this
all right watch out for those lines
those mines are deadly we got something
who's slowing down time is that not me
that's me Mr Brodus brunderson or
branderson Mr Mr broderson
and brodick is that what we decided oh
no dick yeah obviously it's gonna be bro
dick because why wouldn't it be bro dick
Tom I'm definitely going to Tweet the
developers about that I'm sure they get
that sweet every day though right
I'm sure they I'm sure they get
characters requests yeah all the time
product though brodick would be great
yeah because it's got bro and dick in it
oh wow all right yeah no just don't be
on the phone but these explosion runs
are insane do you think
okay
who's making chaos happen right away
that was me
it just exploded everything this oh God
yeah he is he is underpowered
everything is also coming down from the
top of the stage to kill you yeah
what happened
oh my God I'm climbing an explosive pipe
by planting my knife into it I just want
to point that out tonight
the player across from me the red player
is always kind of screwing me over
screwing you over we might be screwing
each other over here like that
everything is falling and killing me
aren't you supposed to do this I don't
know as you climb up the stairs you were
just immediately killed
now I'm playing I'm not climbing up this
yes I'm gonna slow it down whoever's uh
oh you know what we could do what hit
the F1 key
for the no that doesn't work no no no oh
no I'm lost it's such a good idea it was
like so dramatic where you like just hit
the F nothing happens because like
earlier when I hit the F1 Key by mistake
it slowed down the game but uh maybe it
doesn't work
so the problem is I keep dying right
away wow is anyone else having the
problem you're gonna die a lot oh wow
they're the crates that come flying can
I not relate to that yeah well the
crates immediately start
crushing you oh my God
whoever's this one's on you Judge Dread
oh yeah just brought it up to the top
write it up to the sky I think it would
run I I would write it into the oh you
oh
it's slower right now why is it not I
think it was normal that's just what
it's like
it's like okay this is the one okay God
God damn it spreadshot person oh my god
without you Sean I will give it one more
shot and then we're gonna jump back out
to a different game mode
really didn't need it started off with
an explosion but I know it's an
explosion run oh you jerk [__] there's a
box oh wow oh you you know that would
never be killed by a box keep going keep
going
you got this oh [__] someone knocked me
off my safe platform oh no
why did I do that I attacked the enemy
who was standing right next to the
explosive pipes I feel like we can do
this so here's the thing you don't need
to be firing constantly yeah all you
need to do is fire guns at the enemies
who are right next to you
oh I just jumped off
generally speaking you don't need to
constantly fire yourself all right this
is
oh my God that's a life lesson also Sean
don't forget to use your uh your melee
button oh [__] it was so close yep we
almost had that we can do this all right
I think we got this now I didn't know we
had a melee yeah why button I don't know
if you can break out your cage with it
[__] [__] [__] remember come on don't
shoot everything
like shoot very little oh no
oh no oh my God that did not help oh God
why did it scroll so quickly there
this is madness you guys I know this
girl so quickly sometimes
all right Walker Texas Ranger
I have a very bad weapon for this kind
of stage which is a rocket launcher oh
yeah that one's gonna be real fun
oh I don't know who I was but I was
moving really jumpy man oh no
all right
we got this all right guys
yes slow down
I think once the main pipes start going
that's when it Scrolls up
all right Neo take it slow
watch out for that guy
okay oh oh oh just go go go go up and
around the left around on the left yes
kill that guy
oh
my totally missed who was that was that
you that was me no that was awesome all
right roasting crust and braywald
great work
oh I have a really bad weapon for this
one as well
oh [__] what happened over there
well I didn't scroll so quickly was
because we were all dead yeah we all
died once you all die then it just pans
over automatically pandemonium
all right what if we just went like this
all right are you alive keep going stop
stop swinging nothing
you don't have to swing at everything
God damn it I just need to make it
oh Indiana Jones is so wonderful
oh he is like a freaking Professor like
yeah oh yeah he's a he's a college
professor he's a smart man oh no oh my
God
that's so fast oh I'm still alive why is
it scrolling up
this is gonna be a real tough one you
guys I I agree so they're scaffolding oh
I have a grenade launcher you can't
climb the scaffolding just uh yeah I
know I've done that twice already oh
yeah you cannot climb that for now now
it's going a good it's fine don't shoot
don't shoot constantly whoever okay good
kill that guy kill him you gotta kill
him oh
you left oh man you have to kill the
last guy in order to if you killed Satan
all right I got played again so I'll
probably end up
coming through everything
yeah
killed by Falling everything [__] [__]
[__]
oh you got shot by those guys
okay I got the speech
oh [__] oh no you can't go through that
how did you get so far
all right I'm gonna shoot this tank
it's gonna carve a path for us a path to
Freedom oh no I can't you're stuck on
the bridge
watch out it's gonna go quick right here
why didn't you go quick this time
because we're all alive
the more people who die the faster it
goes looks like oh God
okay oh no no no no
and then we all sell off I got I was
doing fine but then I got to a part
where there's too much ceiling yep when
the people die when people die rock it
off to be able to get out oh so that's
how it works yeah it rolls faster yeah
so stay alive that thing is gonna kill
someone well
that's just good life I don't climb up
there there's no way to get through
there
where the uh the part that we all
climbed around
oh oh
why at the end use y use y for that
that's the only way you're gonna pass
that oh I have a grenade launcher is my
only one only hit Y all right here we go
bromando
so stressful nope yeah this is pretty
stressful
so a lot of these weapons or a lot of
these enemies you don't even have to
engage
yeah that's I don't even know I'm not
even bumming that's why you just gotta
hit Y you got it yeah
stolen yes that's fine I'm just glad one
of us made it oh are we still going
because I thought it was the third
person getting it it would have
okay oh well yeah watch out for that
what the [__] a lot of spikes on this
one guys
oh
I have a bad lift why does it take so
long to get out of the cage it's weird
isn't it
oh oh God watch out for all the watch
out for this watch out for the explodey
things don't fire constantly all right
you say so oh [__]
I was doing well until I had to fire my
gun and that was it oh [__]
shooting kind of kills you in this oh
God why is it like that all the crowns
well there's so much laughter going on
in the back room our producers
oh no I have a flamethrower perfect I
love I do really enjoy like the
randomness and Chaos of this mode
because oh my God oh my God your chance
is vary so much depending on which
character you start with oh no
don't play
don't Engage The Enemy yeah just jump
just run a run past
Conan
mix it
I think it's just a missiles coming from
the heavens
oh
you guys are gonna make it
that's that's oh my God that is a cocky
thing oh my God yeah America let's go
did you both make it uh we did but then
I uh I swiped the red Barrel
let's go oh
careful careful of all the exploding
yeah just don't engage don't engage
don't engage there's like four Dudes on
a bridge all right I think he had to
engage with that one chat room do you
guys want to see more of these explosion
runs or do you want to see some other
games wasn't there another mode also
there's a Time run I think
wow all right yeah there's a so there's
a couple other game modes we can try
I'll leave it to the chat room just let
us know keep doing this or try something
new on screens God damn it sometimes
this girl so slowly
I had that one I had to stop I had to
stop running
this does not let us out of our cage
like oh my God yes you're not
immediately let out oh my god oh there's
a lot of exploding oh there's no way to
actually get through here
I'm gonna make sure I'm gonna make it oh
no nosebleed
Justin climbed all the way to the top of
that is that I got crushed by a box with
the American flag on it
all right the chat wants to see another
mode so after we all inevitably die here
I don't know we might all
seems so unlikely are you witnessing the
same thing one of you is just hammering
on the r trigger
and almost you Justin Hayward on that
time it was me all right we're gonna
we're gonna try another game mode or as
the chat calls it game brode get it huh
all right so that was explosion run we
can try race mode race mode there's a
level editor on this level Liners level
editor is probably not going to be right
so who's on player two I'm player three
player four one nice come on eh
because I'm number one
so what is which one is this timed yeah
this isn't race okay so I'm gonna oh my
God
oh I forgot that I forgot there's like a
dash button isn't there what's the dash
button
the left bumper to start going so fast I
I oh I totally won that one right yeah
no I won that one I won that one I was
player three no I'm orange yeah you were
player three now you're not anymore
remember
that was that alive nobody I think it
glitched out
freestyle
why do I only have one Circle
let's walk into that guy's gun
no don't forget about Walker Texas
Ranger oh wait what's up
tied
guys you got this
we're like really quiet because it's
more so yeah we're so focused yep
there's less chaos in this mode there is
okay we're just avoiding it yeah
well now that we've stopped constantly
shooting everything did I win that one
why'd I not win that one
I was I got the furthest where's my
character I I died right away player two
is a super jerk I wasn't even on the
you're not gonna make it
you're not gonna make it player two
no I'm gonna make it no I don't think
you are oh I am I think do I know I
would quit calling you player too why
because of poop
what yeah oh see that you got to the
flag and you couldn't finish the job
I saw one that's all right all right
we're gonna give this one more go hey
we're why did everybody not start this
time no I didn't start last time I
wasn't even there but somehow I got the
point I think this mode might be a
little uh underbaked a little janky yeah
it's certainly no explosion line no
explosion mindless kill that guy
you really I remember yeah yeah you got
to it I beat it with Indiana Jones too
great work everybody yeah I don't think
that's supposed to happen
yes the screen is not supposed to look
like this is what happens after you
liberate a country yeah have you ever
liberated a country Justin I don't think
your faces are supposed to do that guys
I think uh I like the music though
this is going I I can you guys put out
I'm pretty sure this is the end of the
stream right we won
this is America we won this is it we
beat broforce look at all the fireworks
yeah we should just end the stream here
what time is it
it's 58. oh okay well so we're like
three minutes from the normal end of the
stream and the game just I think it may
have just crashed on us because look at
the background there's all explosions
this is perfect it's really yeah it is
and look at Justin's looking at his
phone like yeah he's checking you're on
the camera right now yeah come on man
of course a professional day
well that was very fortuitous because it
is the end of the stream anyway so thank
you all very much for watching Chris
Waters should be back as the host of
multiple players he might get he might
get Albany fever though
Albany fever yeah it might be
Cooperstown come on man I don't know
you're in Upstate New York City
um anyways thank you all very much for
watching thanks to these guys for
filling in stopping to these guys thanks
and thanks us thanks so much out there
all the Bros out there for watching this
we appreciate it we'll see you next week